Speaker 1: All right, over the weekend, I was
just getting email after email after email from
people in the audience saying, David, look, here's
another one of these prominent anti boxers who
just died of covid. Here's another one of these
prominent anti maskers who just died of covid.
Here's another one of these ivermectin people who
just died of covid. I had three stories actually
planned for today. We're only going to get to two
of them. And I think these are important to go
over for a few different reasons, which we're
going to get to the third one, we're actually
going to get through tomorrow because it's a
little different. It's a militia member who
was also anti mask and anti who died of covid.
But let's just jump right into the first one.
We now have the third conservative radio host
who condemned the covid vaccine, who has died
of covid. If you didn't understand what was
going on and you just zoomed out, you might say,
wow, being a right wing radio host seems really
dangerous in the United States in some way.
This is Marc Bernier. He was a mainstay on talk
radio in Daytona. This is the state of Florida.
A conservative Florida radio host who spoke out
against covid vaccines died after a weeks long
fight with the virus, marking the third radio
personality to die from coronavirus who publicly
rejected vaccines. The death of Marc Bernier,
65, who was a mainstay on talk radio in Daytona,
was announced Saturday night by the radio station
NDB that he was affiliated with for three decades.
It is with great sadness that W NDB and the
Southern Stone Communications announced the
passing of Marc Bernier, who informed and
entertained listeners on W NDB for over 30 years.
We kindly ask that privacy is given to Mark's
family during this time of this time of grief. I
think that it would be more useful if they didn't
hide the cause of death in these announcements.
This is an it's almost exactly like the Phil
Valentine thing where the radio station statement
doesn't mention the anti VAX element and the covid
death. Even if it's not, you don't have to attack
the person, but just say of covid folks, let's
send this together, get the vaccine, wear a mask,
wear recommended. There would actually be some
more that comes from this that would be useful.
Bernier was known for inviting different
viewpoints on the show, including Democrats,
but had publicly railed against vaccines. The
Daytona Beach News Journal reported Bernier
had been hospitalized since August seven, when
Florida's Democratic Agriculture Commissioner
Nikki Freed in July urged people to get vaccines
on Twitter by saying the greatest generation had
to defeat the Nazis to preserve our way of life.
You're only asked being asked to get a shot. So be
a patriot, Bernier replied. On the platform should
say. Now the U.S. government is acting like Nazis
get the shot died of covid likened the vaccine
to back to Naziism debt of covid. OK, Friede is
challenging. Florida Gov.. Rhonda Sanderson, 22,
said My heart goes out to his family and friends.
We covered this story. Previously on August 4th,
another Florida conservative radio host who had
criticized the coronavirus vaccine, Dick Farrell,
also died from complications. Ferrell had worked
at several radio stations and was a fill in anchor
on Newsmax. He strongly condemned the vaccine
posting on July 3rd. Why take a vaccine promoted
by people who lied to you all along about masks
where the virus came from and the death toll?
Of course, there were no lies about masks in
March of twenty twenty, Dr. Fauci said it's
probably not necessary for the general population
by April of twenty twenty. Fauci and everyone
else was saying we now know more where the mask
lied about where the virus came from. That's
just lab leak hypothesis stuff that's unproven
and lied about the death toll. It's actually been
the state of Florida that has been playing fast
and loose with the statistics and actually
that I've mentioned this before. But let me
just slightly digress. Over the weekend, I got
a bunch of emails from people saying, David,
why do Florida's death numbers look so good? Any
time you look at Florida's death count, it's low.
It's just collapsed. This is a game Florida is
playing. And I told you about it a week and a half
ago. What Florida is doing is they are reporting
covid deaths a full week at a time for the
previous week. The way most of these websites work
is if Florida doesn't report cases for yesterday,
it shows up as a zero. If Florida doesn't
show report cases, deaths for the day before
it shows is zero. So what Florida is constantly
doing is saying, OK, it's now August 30th.
Here's the death numbers for August 22nd. Twenty
third. Twenty fourth and. 25Th and those go crazy,
but then because they've not reported the
recent dates, it crashes to almost zero
and then next week they'll report the numbers for
this week. The point is, Florida is playing a game
where by delaying reporting by a
week and doing a week at a time,
it always looks like the last five to seven
days are just looking really good in Florida.
It's just a game. You have to understand that
that's what's going on. And now to right wing
Florida radio hosts. Plus Phil Valentine from. Was
it Georgia, Tennessee, I think Tennessee, multiple
ActiveX right wing radio hosts have now died
of covid. Let's go on to the next similar story